one two one two one two or two and two
okay welcome back to the true Geordie
podcast right it's a weird vibe today
the last time it felt like this for me
was when we were in that [__] bomb
shelter a few years ago and the London
bombings were happening of course that
we weren't just to be clear if you
didn't see that but we weren't in a
bombshell that cause of the London
bombings yeah we just couldn't afford a
proper studio yeah but it also just
happens to be really efficient places
that's 50 square - yeah that's great
yeah toothless Russian fellow who rented
it me was great yeah I thought we said
we weren't gonna swear it'll only is a
strange podcast because to me it's just
fear isn't it isn't it that's why I feel
weird well we we need to make a decision
at the beginning of the podcast because
I've seen some other youtubers and well
I say other people on YouTube we're not
youtubers if you say the name of the
thing the thing is yeah the alcoholic
brand of virus takes away modernization
does it really yeah even if I just say
the word so we're just gonna call it
self isolation then we're just gonna
call it to redo that that the ting is
what you recall it the Fosters virus
sure yeah that's or whatever you want
something I yeah we need money right
we're now more than ever to head over to
our patreon matter that's coming soon
this race before we start yeah this is
such a [__] early stage of this [__]
to do a podcast we don't know how Bad's
gonna go it'd make it much better
fingers [__] crossed obviously it may
get much worse the chances are people
watching this they're all gonna be
affected in somewhere by this [__] and I
just want to sort of take this seriously
a bit at the start we always have a
laugh and we always try and yeah and
hopefully that'll pick people up dealing
with the situation yeah and that's how
we are but at the same time I don't want
people to think I'm not respectful of
the [__] that people are going to be
going through either your effect that
have directly indirectly through a
family member or you're just heavily in
convenience where your livelihood is and
threat I'm really heavily inconvenient I
genuinely like I mean uh jh1 from your
haircut the other day and me Bob I could
see me me Parvez a proper hard-working
block good man worried the worry is
there for business owners you know how
and how how can we survive this [__]
like not just physically but financially
so yeah I feel for people out there
right now and we're affected by like our
biggest moneymaker is spa and that's how
we make our living and now with that
shutdown
there's worry there's it's just [__]
for everyone right now there's a lot of
in and there's so many things you can't
know
so people are panicking even more if
some if it was your norther is scurry
yeah if someone had said three months
and we'll be completely done absolutely
fine then maybe people feel differently
about it and it would change the economy
people would still be investing but I
feel like I've got your element yeah
I've got a little so I think I've had it
basically I've come out and say that and
I know that might sound I don't want to
be that guy and I don't want to come
across that way I haven't tweeted this
out when everyone's been like who's the
first youtuber to get the corona Rose
because I don't I don't know if I schewe
in the sense of I haven't got a piece I
haven't had the test on yeah but as you
know laws at the beginning of February
people might remember because we
mentioned it I was ill I don't want to
scare people but I just want to be
honest at the same time and also we
should say the virus affects everyone
differently exhaust so so there are
common symptoms you might have a really
low level version of some Idris Elba for
example on Twitter is I didn't even know
still don't feel anything
yeah I've tested positive I feel fine so
you look at it resolved oh yeah he is in
the shape that you wished he's in shape
on shape yeah peak physical condition
interest in real life now just read
times on three separate occasions every
time I just look across he satin same
rose me when it's going see Dave
Chappelle item he'll nod and we both
know the formulary Paris Rome and him
remember and he went he had a big crowd
but didn't see and he he is if you could
have think thought of a person to
contract the virus and then feel like
the virus it would be a dream of the
rock oh yeah but
or literally John so for me you've got
your coffee coming in shoulder Ejiofor
turning in for it's actually I've had in
a week because I won't go to coffee
shops right I'm not I'm not just saying
this I've had the flu not man flu the
real flu about 10 12 years ago some it
it was horrible and I remembered it
specifically you know all those shitty
symptoms that you get but the beginning
of February I had what felt like just
flu times 5 times 10 it was like really
extreme version of flu yeah breathing
became real difficulty every time I
wanted to breathe in and out the the
compulsion cough was just constantly
there was it dry cough yeah and but it
was like own ignoring like you know how
sometimes you can be ill and you can
sort of zone out I get a little bit I
couldn't like yeah every breath every
single [__] time I wanted to just
breathe and no nice thing said me I was
like every breath you take every move
you make it'll be with you it's [__]
me up yeah so and then it was the sweats
I'm sorry to say this people at home
probably you know what no no relax
I had to put a towel down on the bed
because I was sweating to such a degree
my temperature I was through the [__]
roof luckily I'm gonna sound like such a
[__] I've got air conditioning that's
broken enough where the time was working
yeah and that was like something but
even with it I didn't even know it's a
difference yeah I was my temperature was
through the roof and I remember an
aching feeling that was like right in my
bones and I was like [__] hell is
this like this is nothing I've like econ
compared to a hangover
you can't like I had an issue when I was
like 3 years old where I nearly died
yeah that's the only time I can remember
being such a like a state of just this
isn't going away like it was it was it
felt like because normally you have an
illness 2 3 days you feel better
[__] lasted two weeks for me permanently
like it was pretty much as bad always
that I didn't give a day give or take 1
or 2 days either side of the edge but it
was so bad for so long and I've got to a
point I don't know if I said this to you
or homem how I said I was like [__] like
flu can be really bad corneal and I can
see and I remember saying literally I
can say oh this could kill someone like
this is [__] terrible now it took us
a week after that so three weeks in
total just to feel normal and be able to
go to the gym and do normal stuff I
don't
I've got no piece of here but I say I
had the virus but when you look at all
of the symptoms and how I was feeling
and at the timing of it because let's be
honest like that was around the time
when they said we've got two confirmed
cases in Newcastle you know the law came
down the lack of knowledge that we have
about how many people had it for me
given the outbreak and the levels of
numbers that were getting just from
people who are being tested and this so
many who aren't yeah it stands to reason
that this had been in the country for
months before I felt the way I did at
least a month or two yeah that is one
thing we should definitely say on this
is neither and I don't even think we
need to point this out but neither of us
are scientists absolutely and so when
you're saying things like is clearly
been in the country you're not really
you're not got any data to go pure
speculation what I what my opinion is
like like what we said I thought this is
really early dis we don't know there's
so much we don't know right now and I
don't know this gonna affect the world
and and I'm just hoping that there's a
bit of an overreaction and it isn't as
bad as what we're fearing but like yeah
I think I had it just thought it was flu
got over it and then you know from when
I first felt like that this well that's
like six weeks ago now so now we're at
the point where it's like really kicking
off and people are speaking about it so
I'm like oh [__] like that that was that
perfect profile I've come and then you
know the size of me you know when you
look at who it would affect more I'm you
know I'm overweight yeah officially on
the BMI six yeah BMI doesn't really mean
anything
you are also overweight I'm
big yeah I mean so it probably would
affect me a little bit more I guess but
that's I think that is also the kind of
thing that is there are a lot of people
I know that are feeling anxiety around
maybe not even them getting it but like
their parents but for more an overweight
friend to be clear I feel fine yeah I'm
100% again I feel fine
but that's but that's what we're worried
about that that's where the real fear is
coming from is when we all are on social
media it's the vulnerable people who we
know it's not generally ourselves and I
think that there are a few things
statistics have been particularly
unhelpful in this and the broad way that
governments have spoken about it has
basically been so precautionary that has
stopped people from really considering
the actual ramifications of it so they
go well 7 in 10 people in the country
might get it and I imagine a lot of
people go well I'll be one of the three
then and you're like right but we can't
all be one of the three seven out of ten
of us so at least three of us if you are
in there take would have it but when you
go down the rabbit hole of Statistics
online I mean none of it's good nothing
no the one thing we can all agree as no
one's going we're all gonna be fight not
read that any well know apart from
Donald Trump now there was a point where
he was sort of get there was his
coverage coverage we cover that I'm true
news like a week ago some of the most
hopeful covering in terms of this aging
badly I've never seen a comment age
quicker in my [__] life yeah than
Donald Trump good just 15 we've covered
it we're fine not only that but multiple
comments where this man is we're at one
point he said it's like magic it'll just
go away hey yeah and I was like what
where it's like a calendar in a tissue
through all of the time yeah and all the
specific dates where he said this is
fine we've got this there was one point
where he said and I found this quite
funny he said we're not gonna let the
people who have the virus
off the boat because I would raise the
number of people in the country who have
got the virus now it's like oh gosh if
we just remember Bill and I'm not on a
trauma for Trump particularly I mean I
just I just I'm not I don't have a
palette
his comedy but I mean the guy's funny
not in the ways meant to be yeah
Bill Clinton lost this job offer getting
his dick sucked pretty much
although shown that we would have you
believe otherwise well but Donald Trump
you know he certainly beat that
he's almost actively bad sometimes like
and there's people behind him you go
like there's pretty in crazy it's pretty
crazy and then obviously in the UK we've
got Boris Johnson who just seems to want
to pass all the responsibility on
someone else so in some ways what do you
know about this he goes why no the
scientists I mean I must submit didn't
tell me with confidence this whole [__]
is making us say a lot of things about
like the world that we're living in we
were living in quite a world where it
was it was almost there was so much
luxury that we could afford to have a
bad prime minister or a bad president or
someone that didn't sue everyone well
cuz crisis doesn't really come though
you know what I mean yeah or at least
you know we didn't think if not real
Christ yeah you know and so all of a
sudden we've got a situation where we're
like oh [__] we can't actually afford to
have someone who might be incompetent at
the top of the hierarchy we need someone
have someone who's actually good what a
Luthor yeah and that's not either of
these men it's it's a kind of like a you
know the best of both worlds in it I've
seen a similar meme on to another day of
Eddie hall Porter to Chara OD Holtz it
was a comparison between the cues that
they had for the Russians in the world
war and fighting over the toilet rolls
you know and it's like oh my god like
and I think that's one of the things
that we're saying we're like the
selfishness of regular people in this
time comes out and like it reminds me of
like what Tupac said when he was like
fear is stronger than love fear is
stronger than love and not in everyone
there's a few who will who will walk
into the fires there will be the good
people to try and save people's lives in
this shitty soap that's but generally
speak many in this it's a lot of [__]
people out there in there like so it's
coming alive like we're seeing that
there should be a good comparison
between what's going on for you in
Newcastle and what's going on for me in
London as well because I think we're
probably seeing different things but
then there are similarities
their level of panic is very different
so first of all I think it starts out
where do you want to go into the toilet
roll thing and the hoard
because initially it started out some
people and I noticed this were taking
toilet roll and I was thinking oh okay
well but it wasn't all gone and this is
little bit but by the end of the day as
in any supermarket a lot of shelves are
empty because the supermarket's stack up
and then open the next day and
everything's on the shelves people took
the time to then go in when the shelves
were empty take a photo and go all the
shelves are empty and I'm like that
normally happens in supermarkets like
normally we get out of stock a thing
without panic people and then so people
went down the river [__] we've gotta go
and get as much as we can because for
some reason we'll all take more shits in
this time I don't like the corona just
at the X virus it doesn't give you the
shit's from what I know
no but this but maybe anxiety does or
maybe it's also that nervous suppose how
long am I gonna have to be out what if
we do have to isolate the funny right so
I'm obviously I'm with a Kosovan right
she was I you know there's certain parts
of the world where they don't wipe their
ass like even in Eastern Europe
somewhere they use jugs of hot water to
like wash it off and she was like so the
fact that we're hoarding toilet paper is
almost also in in the event of like you
know their apocalypse yeah the last
thing I'm gonna be worrying about this
title like I said if you've got hot
running water in an apocalypse well
let's just say the plumbing was just
working yeah German in the shower after
ash it would be much more convenient in
the shower after [__] and just wash it
off there's nothing more satisfying
crying this is such I'd never thought
there is nothing I'd imagine most people
would say if I've got a limited amount
of storage yeah you best believe I'm
keeping supplies to live off of I'm
worrying about like you know the [__]
they are it also reduces snow ironic
that after everything I've been through
in the past year yeah it all comes back
to this yeah
it also brings out lava the hilarious
thing was so there's a Sainsbury's and a
Marks & Spencer in the place where I
live mmm Sainsbury's no toilet paper
Marcin Spencer the shelves are
absolutely full exposures no one in
marks and snow sir but that's the thing
but it was exactly the same price but no
one who shopped in Sainsbury's was
thinking to go into Marks & Spencer and
price that price ooh yeah and I was i if
you really are panicking then you could
just take it quit tripping there so it
shows like people's primal instinct is
just to grab things like I went shopping
and this is one of my tips for surviving
Korona I was I went shopping maybe a few
days before it all got very serious and
as I was walking around I saw an old
woman put her arm onto a shelf and just
clear the shelf until then I was like I
was going for that it was minestrone
soup if anyone's wondering yeah I was a
bit annoyed because minestrone is a good
oh it's a good one it's including isn't
good one and other people just weirdly
looked at her and started to do the same
it's like what hey y'all why this is
what I hate people and I love pretty
well but I hate people it's the
psychology it's but I'm not like that
like personally I've got a mind of my
own so I don't look at someone and go
yeah I bet I do what they're doing yeah
I'm not that I'm the opposite of that
which if anything I'm like [__] that you
know and not to be old David Icke but
we're so easily controlled for this very
reason because we react in the same
predictable [__] way every [__]
time psychology is a huge part of this
it's mass psychology yes and it's we all
doing the same thing
we'll worry and and for me personally
I'm less afraid of death in the average
person or not and I don't mean that in a
I'm a hard guy kinda way but I'm just
I'm well acquainted with with it you
know I'm very aware of it's coming for
all of us yeah and I don't panic the way
other people I'm much more frightened
having a [__] life while I'm here than
my death you know what I mean
which i think is the right way around
ironically but I think most people don't
view it that way but yeah it's it's it's
interesting because I've done jobs where
and I've known a lot of people who've
done jobs where they put their life
online and you have to get acquainted
with that fear and they become less they
don't [__] themselves the way a regular
person do itself however you're in
control like we had a chat about this
you're in control of that situation
whether you're in diving or you're a
firefighter or whatever whereas this is
something that we just can't predict and
that's not in there so there's extra
fear on top of that there but still the
level of pot right now the level of
panic it's gotten to I don't think I
fully agree with I don't think it's not
helpful in in a situation where we need
to remain calm but it's also actually
not I think we should look into the
numbers at some point in the podcast
that we do have yeah because I don't
think that the level of fear reflects
the actual numbers that we've got so far
like there's so many things where I'm
like we can't know for a fact that the
level of deaths that we're looking at
over across the world I'm sure it's a
higher number and but but I'm sure that
also the level of infect the people is
even higher than what we're actually
aware of if anything what how many
people go and get tested like so many
people haven't well yeah there's not
enough tests for approach that's not
enough test but there's also a lot of
people don't see any point in testing on
mass because they're like a lot of
people just get it not be very well
exactly so and that alone means it's
going to be way higher do you think
though people fear death or do you think
people fear the death of a loved one or
do you also just think some people also
just fear because I think I was also
seeing interestingly you might have the
same in Newcastle like culturally
there's a bit of obviously as a melting
pot in London and particularly where I
live is like there's there's African
people there's people from Eastern
Europe there's people particularly
Turkey there's there's people from all
different continents coming together and
you see how different people deal with
things so certain shops are open certain
shops are closed certain shops are open
but you know you can only do certain
things in there
and the different ways that different
cultures are dealing with it is quite
interesting Lee as well and not only
that but you talk to someone and I'm
like oh I I thought if if I me I would
be like right I'll always have the TV on
news so if there is a government
announcement or something like that then
I'll be able to keep up with it other
people don't have a TV they don't know
what to watch they don't know where to
watch they don't know if they don't even
know really some people don't know who
Boris Johnson is I was having a chat in
a cafe with someone and the guy was like
who and I was like Boris Johnson the
prime minister and the guy was like oh
yeah I don't know it was I don't come
from here Wow okay and you realize like
the level of misinformation or a lack of
knowledge that most people don't I think
I got it I got to applied and personally
where once I realized how this was going
to impact us financially as well having
no football and stuff like mmm I'm gonna
take a person to put food on the table
I'll do whatever I've got to do so to
have that power removed from me so
frustrating and like [__] and I think
it's important and not think totally
about myself and my own situation but
like naturally you're gonna you're gonna
think about that and so once I realized
how it was going I just saw I'm gonna
take a little bit of a I'm not gonna
read Twitter as much today because it
was every [__] tweet and and I don't
think that that helps so many people who
really it's it's it's a bit like when we
did the Caroline Flack situation site
yeah but you should just shut the [__]
up shouldn't you cuz you're just a dumb
couldn't like me people yeah yeah yeah
and that's why I choose to keep my mouth
shut and do it on a podcast well welcome
back where's any hours of us chatting
ironically there's a no but there's a
disclaimer with this and it's in context
whereas yeah you know 140 characters and
people just coming up with any old
bollocks and and I feel like so many
people were making it worse
I felt like god you're stressing me out
now so god knows what your your
followers are feeling like you know
actually when you're an influencer are
quote-unquote yourself you know the game
so you know what's being played out and
people are using as sad as it is they're
using the coronavirus for to capitalize
on and just
some degree if people could point the
finger at us but I mean what the [__]
else are we going to talk about no no
like we are a staple of YouTube right
people come to us to hear definitively
what really needs to happen what no
one's going to a [__] you know a
commentary channel and going tell me
whether I need to go and buy more toilet
rolls like they'll come here stop buying
toilet roll right so I guess what I'm
saying is how I feel is where the nation
is bracing for an impact right now right
so we truly haven't felt the full impact
any any we're not even there entirely so
everyone's like you know like they're on
an aeroplane and it's the anticipation
head between the knees hold like we're
gonna hit the water any second in sake
and then it might be that we we actually
oh the plate we're not I'm not even on a
plane it was just a jump me it's four so
I jab me toward the door yeah you know
yeah the point is at the pain level that
we're anticipating right now is is
monumental because of the the level of
scare mongering that some big voices out
they are doing when really it might not
be that bad now this is the thing it's
best to err on the side of caution and I
think it's it's better if governments do
go or let's be super careful let's what
they're saying is dip the curve type
thing yeah and all of these precautions
should be taken it sombrero is Boris say
Oh common sense should be in there as
well you know that you know one thing we
do know is the vast majority of people
are gonna get through this and it isn't
this isn't the twenty eight days later
and some people are treating it like
it's resident even type [__] it isn't
that it's not the end of the world I
agree with what you're saying can also
caveat that saying the problem was the
statistics that people are putting out
there as well as they're talking about
mortality rate and they're also talk
about how many people will get it coming
through this alive whilst it might be
seen as an achievement you know if it
does go to the worst-case scenario
doesn't mean that people wouldn't lose
someone close to them absolutely I think
that is where the nuance is lost and it
really doesn't feel like the people
announcing on TV or the people talking
about on television have maybe they
can't interact
how emotionally difficult that would be
because they just have to deal with
getting something done but it doesn't
seem like that is a big thing right it
doesn't seem like that is it's not the
center didn't it's not the center of the
conversation which really it should be
really maybe should be something that
people should be thinking about more is
whilst you know someone might make
through this alive they could lose
someone that's extremely close to them
and that isn't necessarily making it
through this unscathed that's the
problem 100% and I'm definitely as I
said at the start of the podcast I don't
want anyone to think I'm thinking
different now I just feel like there's a
balance that we're not we're not getting
that right at all yeah and that's also
because people by the way in the same
way as you have been told that your
bottom line is gonna be affected because
there's no football there's no nothing
to cover you know things like the Sun
and people like that are seeing this as
[__] we can't cover football anymore so
we're gonna get less clicks so what I
noticed was original the original prime
minister speech came out as one article
and it was like here it is broken down
by the second speech people have worked
out we can do an article for each point
that he's made in there so when I wanted
to find everything in one place it was
very difficult to find it because
everyone was going here's the thing
about older people one article about
older people here's the thing about
self-isolation one thing about that I
wanted all that in one article but you
can't monetize that in the same way so
people are already working out how to
make clickbait for the virus and that
worries me because it also means we
don't have a very efficient system of
distributing that's deliberately not
deliberately inefficient to mean that I
have to take ten times to find what I
want but I wish things as so many of
this we covered in the car alone
ironically yeah and it's just
reaffirming the but with with the
Caroline flux situation it was like are
they sort of they're making a victim out
of one person here and they get this
squeezing the juice out of the death of
one person's sick as that is and now
they're doing it four thousand thousands
of because more potentially it's it's
more about the potential death pit and
it should all or almost be seen as like
this should be punishable in a way
really because you're you're literally
you're doing a disservice as a
journalist to to a level which could be
almost seen as criminally negligible
where you're actually hurting people not
just giving them the [__] the real issue
is now that the people who should be
punishable and our friends with the
people who are at the top so those
people are never going to be punished
what you need those two things to hate
each other and they just don't hate each
other enough the one thing that I want
to say sadly this isn't stoppable now
but it is it is manageable in somewhere
like we can we can dip the numbers with
techniques that they're trying implement
I don't feel like they're acting very
quickly yeah you don't feel reassured by
what you see on task and that's the one
thing is you're you you're very clear in
your political beliefs whereas like I've
always been sort of on the fence and I
just saw Egypt with its own deniable
house ship boris has been here this is
not coming from like let me be
absolutely in a position of like it's so
uncertain he is offered no leadership
yeah he is offered nor reassurance he is
offered so little information about what
to do and how detect I mean he was
rattling on about how I've been shaking
hands with many people oh yeah I shake
every one of their hands and I'm like I
thought we weren't supposed to do like
just wrong with my [__] dick you know
but let me be can I just have one thing
to do I don't think Corbin would have
dealt with it any better
so I'm not I'm not criticized and I
don't think the other thing about Corbin
I'm not saying he was a better leader
now he was a more selfless human being
than him yeah and for that reason if
there was a bullet to take for the
better of the people I think he would
have been much quicker to jump on a bomb
yeah
for us there's not using bad analogies
but yes I see what you're saying yeah
it's that it yeah you get where I'm
going
yeah he'd be much quicker to basically
do the right thing and take [__] for it
yeah rather than self preserve yeah and
I do think clearly Boris's self
preservation
he's the thing though I think in the hue
one come out and and put himself out
there is showing he's
holding back because he doesn't know how
this is gonna go exactly and and if you
come out and actually say that you'd
actually get more respect from me so
that was at least something and that but
that's the point that that I think there
was a I was watching a stream by
physician somewhere and he was talking
about how you do deal with you know the
spread of a virus and he said some
action is better than waiting and see
how this plays out and so he was saying
just trying to do anything would have
helped weeks before and that would have
made you much better and I think you can
almost don't want to invoke World War
two here but it was the fact that
Britain when they were trying to placate
Hitler and we're going let's try to make
a truce with him people saw that as
inaction and that's why Churchill came
out on the right side of history because
he was and when he takes some action
rather than going let's just see what
happens and work it out as we go and the
same needs to be done with this we're
just any leadership will get you on the
right side of history and I think Boris
doesn't realize and he's probably got
his head down at the moment because he's
from these elite colleges where you're
taught that basically you are one of the
ruling classes you are the people who
are made to rule so you'll probably do
the right thing in the end anyway you'll
be alright he is coming out on the wrong
side of history and ultimately we will
see him as one of the worst prime
ministers yes I agree I mean it's just
clear as day like yeah like I said I I'm
not insinuating sure we should be
panicking and going crazy but the fact
is is like I'm just astounded that how
little instruction we've had from the
supposed leader of the country and to
add to that the reason that people are
buying toilet roll like so much the
reason that people are panic buying is
because they don't have anyone telling
there's no go there's no guidance so
people are panicking and for some way
reason we're blaming the people buying
the toilet roll rather than the people
who aren't giving us the guidance that
they for example we've talked about this
guy a lot but Piers Morgan yeah you know
and sort of pointed the finger at Boris
and I agree and on that I fully agree
this is the thing with piers I agreed
with him on that but he then brought a
guy on his show yeah who was an expert
in the field and then because he wasn't
getting the answers here because Pierre
one of the worst scare monger of the law
in my opinion his number one actual
number one of that and he brought an
expert on who was actually seeing some
very reassuring things now I don't know
if they were right I don't know what but
this guy was being very reassuring and
appears to shout at him doubt yeah and
actually the way peers reacted I was
like oh this is really bothering ya
you're so hell-bent on panicking
everyone and having this it turn into
mayhem that you're now shooting your son
the foe because what you said about
Boris was right but now you're [__]
it up because you're showing your vested
interest in this is for that team go in
and it I was just like you really are
scum you you're like an actual bad
person like like it's so sad because
peers has played a very smart game in
his career where what he's done is he's
a smart man and he says some very good
common-sense things and in amongst that
he litters in hateful [__] yes
plausible denial so what people do is
they sort of comfort or you speaks
common sense and and along the way he
sort of holds their hand and leads them
down the path of hatred and by that time
they're fans and it's gone too far and
he's got this Legion the people who
would believe anything he said yes he is
i I'm not even gonna go out and like go
off with all the insults he's just a bad
guy yeah his motivation in life is is
one that is so deep-rooted in himself we
do live in a society where there's such
luxury at the top that we can afford to
have people that are so complacent that
we can just go yeah fine we'll just get
on with it but now we're like [__] the
luxury might be going away and we've
elected people who might not be good at
dealing with this it's bringing home
some realities that maybe we needed mmm
there are there is an element of it of a
bit of a reality check of this that it
might help us in the long run because
it's it's almost holding a candle to
these people and going are you good are
you good are you good are you good and
it's not about right-wing or Isis you
find out a lot there are real people
yeah and unfortunately I've been tested
with that a few ohms in my life and if
you find out a lot about yourself in
those moments but yeah I really hope
that this does shine a light on those
because I don't know I think we got or
we cut it wrong online a lot we like
Twitter is not you know we're how is the
wind blowing here that is not like
Twitter thought and Levi will win in the
election yeah and it lost by a landslide
yeah Twitter is wrong most of the time
Twitter isn't the real world you know I
mean so it's quite less i I hope that
this is making more people wake up to
reality I think it also shows there's a
lot of and we we were saying this about
when we were talking about online
culture in general a lot of cultures
meeting together
it shows how inadequate the systems that
we currently have are to deal with
cultural indifference and also to deal
with the issues that we have and
actually that whilst we're encouraged
that Twitter is a good way of talking or
Facebook's a good way of talking here in
stems a good place to post your photos a
lot of the tools we have for dealing
with modern society aren't actually
adequate for dealing with the problems
we have so the problem is today's world
as opposed to like world war is you know
we had Winston Churchill given one
address to the world on a wireless and
the family gathered round
nowadays you got social media Facebook
Twitter Instagram YouTube all of that
where it's so many different people are
giving so many different opinions you've
got a prime ministers like a Churchmouse
not saying enough and you're like who
the [__] do you listen to like it's it's
too many people trying to talk over one
another and most of the loudest people
have got the release clue of what
they're [__] on about yeah but a lot
of those people are trying to maintain
their position rather than they don't
want to change the position so that
they've worked Boris Johnson worked very
hard to get to where he is well he's
worked to get to where he is now he
wants to keep it here's Morgan is like I
have to come out on a site one on one
side and say something yeah so that
people think he's still in the nor he's
still the guy listen do yeah and it's
like you couldn't possibly have had time
to get all the photos pointing speak
definitively he's speaking so
definitively and he's just basing
everything on well Italy this Italy da
and it's like bro like let's wear
everything up you know I mean and listen
if you bring an expert on and you just
shut them down and shout them down
you're a [__] [__] then
the guy couldn't get a word in speaking
of experts so I did find shout out of
the Godfather a podcast and Joe Rogan
did a podcast with yeah what was that
guy's name anyway they'll find him he's
everyone was the last one well actually
yeah no but anyway there was a guy who
came on and really gave some great
analysis of what we're up against how
it's gonna be and and a great interview
I mean that was
that's why Rogan is number one because
he is so able to get though we
struggling at guests like that I mean
we're not in LA for a stop like just to
get that perfect guest that perfect
moment and to get all that good
information out there that people need
to hear it was great it's also
interesting because people are I think
there's we are talking about science as
if science is gonna give us one answer
that guy I think I do think that guest
was a good guest because he gave he
didn't necessarily say this is exactly
what you have to do here's what people
are doing wrong he gave her a broad
quite good advice which was about
self-isolation all those kind of things
instead of saying here's what needs to
be done the government should be doing
is that his why Donald Trump is wrong
blah blah blah it was actually quite it
was interesting that was well before I
think yeah it was more helpful than it
was loaded and a lot of people are
trying to load information right now to
go the government are doing this because
this science says this the government
are doing this because this science says
that but that's not good thing if Rogen
is the main source of information during
a time when you don't go to CNN or Fox
or any of these things it's the same as
when Jon Stewart back in the day on
Daily Show was one of the most watched
people in it people in there like 18 to
30 category were getting menus from a
comedy show on Comedy Central we should
not be getting our news from a podcast
that streams on YouTube like that
shouldn't be the most accurate source
for the most common source of
information yeah it was like such a calm
discussion yeah the guy was obviously
well informed and was able to get his
opinion across without getting shouted
out like I could take this in this is
easy yeah isn't stressing me out
yeah he's saying that he's like look
alright it's it the time to stop it has
gone but we can we can definitely hinder
it and all of that you're not
that's the interesting thing Noakes I
think the US MSU stayed off Twitter
because Twitter felt like such an
inefficient way to communicate well it
just wasn't helping my state of mind in
our u.s. I thought if I'm if I was
getting some actual information from I
just thought me to it as always
poisonous it but it's just particularly
like [__] right now there's so many
dumb people just thinking of coronavirus
jocks that I'm just like really like
that's not the best you do you got you
know any funny thing is like I'm also
err think every time we do like a media
based podcast I was go back to this but
like even in Greece back in the day when
Greece was this great culture I know I'm
not saying it's not culturally brilliant
now but and they had all the gods and
all these stories all analogous to like
modern day in those Oosten all those
hermes was meant to be i think the son
of zeus something like that I loved him
and Futurama as well he was fantastic
and he also gets actually Hermes problem
on the least good delivery companies for
parcels he's won Soros will change or -
yeah I mean give it a try he was a
messenger for the gods as well and so he
would basically he was like the
messenger he was he was God of
communication all those kind of like
they don't know where the [__] you're
cool with this you'll get you'll get a
second he was also seen though as a
symbol of trickery and tricksters and
jokes and those kind of things so what
the Greeks were cooking into a story
about the Greek gods was that whilst you
can represent communication like Twitter
or Facebook or Instagram or a newspaper
you can also represent [__] yeah and
the fact that those two things go hand
in hand and if anything you can't get
rid of the two so Twitter is a great
place for misinformation it's a great
place for hearing that you know
someone's vulnerable when they're not or
that actually a certain group of people
are vulnerable when they shouldn't be at
cetera so it's great to spread the wrong
message I think also in the level of
some people use Twitter as a form of
like therapy just to get things off
their chest sure yeah and and something
at me in that I I don't want to be the
guy receiving that as well because yeah
then nervous energy is not helping my
mum for I know people think I talk about
diving too much but I'm gonna go back
there for one minute because
I was tall in the in the heat of them
like I've been in moments where oh [__]
this is getting hairy new and I'm caught
in [__] ropes and you know when
you're underwater and you're trapped you
panic but there's only one way is to get
yourself out of the situation and is to
be calm and deal you can't afford a
panic in that moment because it's like
and there's some people who have this in
their brain where it kicks in - how can
I be proactive in order to make this a
bad situation for myself and that's the
kind of person I am and in that moment I
got pulled a knife out and just [__]
cut all this [__] and then next thing
I know I'm alright
but if I kept panicking it would just
got worse and worse so when I say people
like that are floating like you get the
you get there's one guy on to it I'm a
good friend riff at the man I'm not
gonna name them because I don't want to
come across as a [__] but they're like
they keep tweeting out like every hour
like everyone needs to just stop
panicking and I'm like you do realize
like you stop you make what I wasn't
actually thinking about panicking yeah
stop everyone remain calm it seemed like
a great ocean road like yeah you need to
cop stop tweeting do you know that cat's
paw like the meme it's like can you just
chill well it's it's it's yeah it's also
most people are tweeting or at least
some I think some people are tweeting
what they're thinking on so they're
tweeting stop panicking and you're like
um is actually for you it's sad when I
think was Gus from geordie shore tweeted
something about the government and I'm
like and actually I read his name this
genuinely I was like when Gus from
geordie shore is telling the government
what they're doing and he's right yeah
but what they need to be doing we got
problems
yeah I mean we shouldn't be looking to
jørgen but here Joe Rogan 50 year old
guy we've got a lot of life experience
generally a very bright block gas from
geordie shore who made a living off
getting piss in Newcastle is actually
seems more smart than the Prime Minister
for a second yeah what the floor he's
more engaged with literally what we
doing here
just sort of yeah that kind of shows the
miss structure or the the problem with
the structure we've got now is like gas
is probably more engaged with the
general population Boris Johnson is the
Boris and Boris Johnson make any sense
Oh what are we look like there's a part
of me that's just like I can't believe
we're living through this [__] as well
this is weird
the the other thing is statistics are
very unhelpful because you here are
1,500 people have whatever in Italy or
2,000 people or 10,000 people or someone
the other day by the time of this
podcast I think were but just over the
7000 worldwide yeah yeah of actual
reported ones obviously there's bound to
be more that we don't know about what
they don't give you is who those people
were so you can't look down the list and
go all right okay so that person was 70
that person was 70 that person was
already in hospital of that person was
like this so you get a very well who is
that in the seven thousand sounds like a
lot but actually if you think of it but
there's a percentage of people globally
that's a very low amount of people it's
it's it's it's minut yeah but that's not
to say I don't take it seriously and
that I'm not aware that it could become
a lot more so I'm not diminishing it by
saying that but I'm also thinking it
isn't great that we don't get those
details because those details so key to
that that it might instead of making you
think [__] we could all die it would
make think ah a lot of these people
seventy I probably go and check on my
grandma make sure she's got enough food
for three weeks all these kind of adult
without a dose it'll make you act
differently the more information you
have and we're not getting very much
information right now we just get a lot
of wash your hands and then a lot of
footballers on Instagram washing their
hair and projections as well that are
based on if you're starting out with
incorrect numbers then any projection
you make from there is automatically
wrong so have you read many numbers yeah
there was a good shout out Lou Thomas
mmm a journalist he quote tweeted a
tweet which was like you know you should
probably read this and it was
specifically about America and it was
based on the number so far we've seen in
other countries China in Italy etcetera
if you'd apply that to America how many
people would die
and it was like 4 million and then it
was like if you apply the restrictions
of movement over 70 zr da dada how many
and brought it down by 50% and then but
in my head it was like we started off
with incorrect numbers like it's very
difficult to know how much so I'm
reading this and I'm finding myself
getting like oh [__] that's that's a
[__] scary number but at the same
time it is the unknown and that I think
ultimately that's why we're scared of
the dark that's why we're you know
they're scared but this fear is just
snowballing and getting worse and I'm
frustrated at the situation because I
from my own personal life and a lot of
people say oh you shouldn't think about
yourself it's like look outside this is
the world we're living in like you have
to think about yourself as well and I
think I encourage everyone to think
about their own life okay to think about
yeah yeah the people who are like
hammering people for worrying about
their own like like people are gonna die
from this it's like well yeah but I also
have to live as well if I you know and
watch my back you can only really help
other people if you're in a good
position if you're sick you can't help
anyways you're if you're if you're
trapped at home you can't help anyone
there's so many different reasons to
think of yourself in this situation but
the fact is you don't need to spend 24
hours day thinking of you it's okay to
spend an hour or two hours okay now
thinking of yourself or looking after
your wife or looking after an elderly
relative that's not a problem it's this
virtue signaling online where which i
think is now more prevalent than it was
before of people going so for ensuring
all those the NBA had shut down NFL is
not on at the moment but the a lot of
players came out and said I'll give some
of my wages to to whoever right add to
the staff who are still working in the
arenas blah blah blah and need the money
and those people tweeted well it
shouldn't be you it should be the owners
of the teams that do this and you're
like yeah but these owners are not
working on just the wages of their staff
their work these guys are billionaires
for a start so they've got massive
businesses they're gonna have to work on
such an overarching plan that they can't
come out and just make one statement and
go I'll cover everything don't worry
they need to work on a massive plan that
might take two or three days but in
those two or three days maybe Pete
gonna get paid anyway but people are
using it as an opportunity to snipe at
someone I have a go them or do that and
I think when fear sets in is well it
makes people behave really aggressively
as well because he and not a natural
thing when you have that backed into a
corner mentality is to sniper it what's
coming towards you all Muslim yeah I
think people are aiming in the wrong
direction sometimes but like yeah for me
personally obviously people know that we
had a mountain to climb last year and
then we've really worked really hard
behind the scenes to get back to where
we need to be financially and do all the
right things and not buy cars and and
and and I've been like solid I nailed
that yeah but we've worked really hard
behind the scenes I think that's fair to
say more than we ever have before so to
have something that's out of my control
[__] that up right in the middle of a
lot of good hard work I've been put in
and have many companies that were
negotiating with and dealing with be in
difficult situations as well just make
everything difficult it was just like I
was a real kick in the balls that and
and obviously like in you know there's
this there's million one things it's the
worry of people I know who could suffer
there's you know you're aware of the
mass hysteria out there but then in the
back it's and what about how do I move
forward through this how am I going to
cope what do I do you know people to pay
a business to and all of that it's just
awful and I'm sure there's a lot of
people out there feel in the same way
and I hope for that reason my hope my
positivity because I do I'm quite a
positive broker in the face of like
adversity and I'm able to look through
it and go alright well this is a
temporary thing I just hope that a lot
of the people who are overreacting who
themselves think they are going to die
immediately as soon as someone coughs in
their direction when that doesn't happen
inevitably and a lot of people who are
overreacting or like you know in in
April hopefully going are we
we're okay messy nail channel here
there's a level of calm that comes over
the world our country especially where
there like right okay well you know
maybe I can focus on the at-risk people
instead of just holding toilet rules for
myself yeah and uh and I hope that the
[__] football comes financial reason
more than anything you know it's
inevitable that football will be back at
some bullet Laura Lawrence promise me
yeah yeah it's love you you've got the
meetings and the Premier League told me
yeah so typically don't worry Lawrence
you'll be okay as I thank will will do
when the Lucas oh yes right if as long
as a lot of people still alive that's
like a title win to me yeah and that's
you know what I mean I'm just putting
that out there because I don't want to
be a fake for any person to pretend that
I'm all about everyone else and there is
a level of like preservation to everyone
selfish uncle said this to me not long
he was like you have to look after
yourself before you can go and look
after other people and you can't you
can't pay someone else's wages if you
don't have the money coming in yeah so
it's all these kind of things uh you you
and I can't split cash that doesn't
exist
looks like otherwise there's no point in
thinking at all just from a when when
all that first happened and I was
getting some phone calls that were like
for Fox if you're imagine here cause
true Charlie making everything about
himself a country but I'm just giving my
honest chart right if we go from last
year when I had that real law to finally
building myself up and almost like
climbing a mountain
you get myself mentally and financially
and and physically out to a better place
I felt like I was you know you I felt
like [__] Mufasa you know like
helpers up and then the Quran I was like
[__] off ya back down you go he was the
doctor shared got whatever it is yeah
Chicano no no that's from jungle all
right they're all the same are stories
skaar yeah so we will now call this car
very yeah so it it's [__] me a bit you
know but I'm man enough to know it's not
nearly [__] me anywhere near as bad as
anyone as many other people will be yeah
and I've heard rumors about like people
died and that haven't been reported as
doubts if Corona tested we can't find
out conclusively exactly so the numbers
you know what I mean or the numbers are
wrong so does you look a little bit
hopeless in the way you're looking away
and I think for me I don't know I think
it's [__] [__] it does show more
though I think things are paused rather
than stop absolutely and but it's it's
remember it's I'm waiting for everyone
to calm the [__] down
so that there's a level of common sense
can be applied because I just the level
of crazy talk I've witnessed and like
even in New Castle people are fighting
over bugger-all as well really yeah me
why I've never seen a women move so fast
to get something Mac they turn into like
Kill Bill ninja [__]
yeah oh of Norway I'm look I was looking
at people now here's another tip sorry
here's another scar tip and geo cut this
here's another scar tip right if you
shopping right go early get there before
everyone else gets there the shelves are
stacked be look for a mum right mums are
smart mums make great shopping list yeah
I was walking around the other day I've
made little shopping she's literally
sitting there texting her mate corn
there's a guy following me right now
sure but you guys he's unshaven he looks
dangerous here's the thing right what
you do is to reduce the risk and make
sure she didn't spot you put your hood
up and a pair of sunglasses will not
break their now I'm not so sure about
yeah brie would just say we do not
recommend it just so that she'll know
following women with your heart she
feels reassured and you always feels
that you're close just let a little
cough every now and again and just and
just some heavy breathing it always
reassures people around us that you
aren't a creep
so I heard I was genuinely at this point
someone else went frozen fish
I went frozen fish brilliant I bought as
much frozen fish as I possibly could now
this is a great thing Brown because you
can freeze the
right fish is healthy fish is nutritious
it's genius but I wouldn't have thought
a frozen fish but my favorite tweet so
far
oh sorry overcook your I was gonna say I
was I was going down the frozen fish
aisle right and I see maybe one of the
sweetest little things that has gone on
is two old men who clearly don't they're
clearly friends were shopping together
to get everything home together and
after that sort of followed them because
I thought I want to see how this ends I
don't mean they're gonna die but I mean
I saw I'm gonna see where they go
or if they're good and they they weren't
gay ultimately or not no it was lovely
to watch though yet they didn't kiss or
hold hands several months of the story
yeah it was a little old wonderful men
have got massive penises as well usually
right or soggy they just can't get them
up yeah I mean but it's the sort the big
ever tent the harder it is to so there's
some got the blood floor on that as well
yeah although at this time I think
emergency prescriptions of Viagra should
be I mean they've got to get one last
it's probably the top of most people's
priorities I'd imagine most doctors are
going to also struggle with erectile
dysfunction huh yep yep how many
milligram okay how many milligrams is
good for Viagra I don't know okay
you've taken one before in my head it
was 50 pop I popped the full one in
whatever one is yeah and then I realized
I'd taken too much instantly yeah
straight away well cuz you're flying a
flag would and also I heard like a
headache really is that what I could
give you I think point is blood pressure
right and and taking them in your
condition
well that this was when I was much
younger right and now would kill me yeah
yeah one viagra gum dead yeah I heard
that for me that's that's the last thing
I'm holding on yeah do you know when
they're out the door 28 days later
yeah it in and for that there's more
meat so they're happy the way it works
if more meat you know actually for those
who love the Pilgrims and podcast with
Travis you're welcome yeah not only that
but I think it would it makes a sausage
also full sauce out feed a family of you
know and the very least would be a
really good hot dog the narratives from
the films don't help like so
has been a lot of end-of-the-world
movies yeah may like them as well I used
to have all seen a lot of them and they
were like it's happening Jeff it's your
football you know and you're watching TV
so I was watching Moneyball the other
day love that film Brad Pitt Jonah Hill
brilliant and really well acting never
swimmer it is it's excellent
you should watch it took them they shook
hands at one point now I in my my my
what are you doing
why did your brains been conditioned my
ruddy yeah I was going Brad don't shake
hands with Jonah like that nice
unbelievable oh that's a no-go
we have seen some some good tweets I
know this one is a little bit gone
footballs canceled no pubs isolated for
for India so you can get all the odd
jobs done flu-like symptoms they know
how badly affects us and they rub salt
in the wounds they've named after a
lager play and that women thought of
this brilliant I like that how many
there were loads of male views out there
going it was it was formulated by
probably you know it's sad when I read
it I burst out laughing why and it's not
funny about because it's such a large
thing right sure yeah but also my
favorite tweet was that the tweet you
just went down to the top tweak but you
see no that isn't my favorite route was
Rudolph who said r.i.p mr. Mayweather
and very sad very sad wasn't like yes
right
my favorite trip was when Badal said
just know if you can't fight you bought
that toilet roll for me yeah that was
definitely my logic in my head I was
like yeah just not on everyone's door
not the way it works
kick the door down I'll be having that
toilet roll thank you very much
and now the event of an apocalypse I
will be straight in the UK it's a it's a
very weak country I'll be fine
sure I'll be just knocking on everyone's
door really when I say locking I mean
putting a size 11 straight through the
[__] thing right okay it's shopping
time now [__]
yeah we're a loud stuff but you know
we're a house that like what are you got
the virus you're breaking in someone's
house with the VIPRE I'll be fine I've
already had admit yes you know I did
Google at the other day I did
I think you might be able to get it
twice yeah you can earlier I did google
it the other day do you know I know it
me as well at one point Boris Johnson in
his speech went if you are struggling
search online and I was like oh thank
you Boris we're joking
Boris yeah we're joke we're joking look
online now google it now here's the
thing right I've been in hospitals quite
a lot recently because the things that
are going on in my life not not
necessarily cause of me he's getting a
penis reduction just sure the one after
this yeah another tweet ezel so what the
what doctors always tell you is don't go
online and search for this stuff I'm
gonna give you an official page that you
need to read but do not read the top
thing that you find on because it's
always the most scary show of course it
is or it's fun suppose literally if I if
I if I feel my bollocks hei I've got it
yeah you know what I mean is that what I
must admit a symptom I think we both
have like that's the thing that's the
where people are going on over this
you'd think everyone had it like you're
not I mean this is but AIDS is the last
time that you can really think in the
there's an outbreak of fear yeah in
America in the UK I think to be honest
everyone worrying about testing positive
after having contact with someone does
remind me of my late teens do you follow
a lot of sort of Nigerian accounts or
anything like that I don't know why I
would follow a few Nigerian guys what do
you mean well there's such a thing is
Nigerian Twitter Brian really yeah I
mean there's there's every kind its own
Twitter I was actually offered because I
follow so many Nigerian people whether I
wanted to switch to Nigerian Twitter the
other hand this isn't funny
you're [__] weird but it is funny
right cuz I see questions about you that
I've never ever known no this is it
brings out of you right brings the best
and the worst things the Nigerian loving
side of you are correct
now an I've always loved Nigeria's great
country I just really didn't expect this
to get on no say it but these guys in
Nigerian Twitter would they were joking
than the jatta Nigerians yeah the
this is this is funny for a lot of
African people in Africa as a continent
because this is the Welcome that our oil
boots kind of look where it's like ha
that because there are a few tweaks that
were saying add this this African
country has closed its borders to
European people coming in and they were
like has it for when the shoes on the
other foot
yeah you guys see how easy is and before
Africa yeah on a boat [__] hunt yeah
yeah getting that dinghy and see if you
make it remove it a lot of people were
were joking that it I think a lot of
people assumed are this virus only will
spread in the countries that we think
are poor and you know there's a million
stream though its main yeah it's gone
mainstream the point values I think
people had always assumed that it would
only be a somewhere like China or Africa
as if I 100 percent was one of those
people yeah you were a race you were
racist no no I submit it I was just told
it was a Chinese thing and a righty for
some reason it was like assisting in
China that was was another thing that
Trump was told I kind of fell for
Trump's [__] don't don't call it the
China virus right as he goes out he goes
this Chinese iris I was like it's not a
Chinese virus all right do you want to
get into what how we think it because
because I once again ultimately all of
this could happen anyway all of my
information has it really come from like
second hand [__] that maybe like a
trump court here in an article there
early on this is when I had it I was
like and I really do believe I have it
I'm not just saying that I'm not I'm not
the guy who needs to have hard at the
virus I know just at this point most
people who know you think you had it
because you've titled this I had the
virus I don't know probably to be honest
with you we need to we need that but I
think that's gonna get to monetize very
quickly maybe we'll call it something
else that alludes to it I think we'll
did something like that I think I had to
jump straight on that today yeah sure I
you know we love them good guy hope he
doesn't get it well we've gone I totally
bought into that you know it's probably
not coming over here and then meanwhile
I'm sitting there sweating [__] dying
in the corner I did think as soon as it
was in New Castle I thought Brian I'll
definitely be one of those two people
yeah because you travel on a train I
come into contact with a lot of people
blah blah blah
that's another thing I used to take the
private jet but since the argument is
that there's a reason why this will get
around by the way there's a reason why
it's almost unstoppable for a lot of
people sex there you go
men right I'm one of them many men many
men many many many many men will risk
sex disease right for [__] right it's
been happening for for for centuries
this isn't gonna stop now
now you think people aren't gonna be
hooking up on tinder no it's still gonna
happen if anything self-isolation is
we're calling it all staying in the
house what's your next sure it gets
boring and lonely and people are gonna
start just saying choppin onobu I think
a lot of people are gonna see how
quickly you can get towards sending a
crazy message to a girl then they would
have thought empathize with ya a lot
more people will have empathy for you
come say week 10 of this also when
you're at the toilet roll at and there
and if anything is order at that point
the stuff that you send I think of a lot
of jokes when I was watching everyone
hoarding toilet yeah this is coming to
me there are so many like you'd be like
sometimes I see where I'm like oh
there's a joke myself you know the mean
where I'm dancing on absolutely yeah
it's it I mean but coronavirus doesn't
affect you in that way so anyway where
we thing that I heard from Malcolm
Gladwell there is another good podcast
by the way which was Malcolm Gladwell
okay is this weird started out this what
you're talking about
yes so Malcolm Gladwell very famous
writer written a lot of things clearly a
very well-read guy it guys done a
research globally and two things that
are going to affect the population right
he was saying a lot of these things and
a lot of people always said it would
start in China and this is no judgement
and Chinese people do you know why cause
II a lot of weird [__] because there are
a lot of pigs in China
really right and I mean the people are
shoving the food in their mouths I mean
literal pigs but the spooks everywhere
yet but not a lot of people keep pigs
domestically what as pets and not as
pets or less I guess I don't know I mean
what they forgot they pigs in the bath
God and that's like yeah maybe not as a
pet maybe they keep like define them
eventually they'll say yeah smart right
because it's a cheap pigs will eat
anything so you can feed them anything
caffeine subscribes those kind of things
but they're also known as the go-between
between birds or as he says he says in
the podcast ducks which apparently hold
a lot of bad things and humans which is
why a lot of medical trials are done on
pigs before they don't on humans because
pigs have an immune system which is
close to our immune system so they can
be the go-between for dangerous viruses
but obviously because there's so much
contact between pigs and humans in a
place where like China where they keep
pigs domestically I know it's very
likely to develop there and see the same
that's why it more than likely developed
and spread like they're mixing with with
pigs too much much if you thought the
FUP so a lot of people same bat focus a
but come from so people say I'm a eater
ate the bat or they [__] about no it
stimulated Leary goes I ate it with with
I bet that guy's like yeah yeah yeah so
you've got you use the battered condom
what you've got well you've got that
wing down your pot just forget it that's
actually considered a bit of delicacy
especially if you're playing Zelda no
but where does a battleship come from
where that Chicago yeah no seriously
mobile that yeah Chicago which is Jim
Carrey reference the weirdest [__] be
fair Jim Carrey is very relevant right
now where where does the butt come from
why are we hearing aids a guy about why
we're hearing that well because that is
a delicacy in some countries well no but
but what why are people insisting it was
about I think the bat they may be found
about that had their thing and then do
you know anything about the so you
Millie I've read no seriously I have
read a little bit about this but I think
as well a lot of this is speculation
this is why could we can we David Icke
needs to be buck on the truth Roger
Potter I mean
that might look tricky so it emerged in
the City of God allow wall cookies of
Wuhan spread to seventy other countries
it originated through natural processes
they're saying not natural processes he
was saying it's more than likely pigs
okay no one knows by the way Brian
no one knows nobody knows two things
oh no on the butter did you see where
they thought it original originated it
was there was a market that was close to
a medical research facility okay and
there was someone who walked down a
Lujan yeah and they were mixing a lot of
sort of movie tropes here so they walk
down the market and obviously in the
Western world I don't think that's a
racist term I think you can say Western
workers were in the West we're not used
to eating snakes bats rats cats anything
that's an act basically Pat things that
we would consider vermin yeah they're
all over this market so snakes being
laid out there's all sorts of [__] you
know no I mean and then they went and
there's the medical research facility so
the two were very close and that's where
they say that's one of the theories that
actually this was medically ended
engineered anyway and then they released
its various e theorems it's funny
because no I'm not saying this [__] like
I'm not saying I believe this but for
four years people like I and Alex Jones
have been insinuating that there was
going to be man-made disease
yeah made to get rid of control the pop
yeah the population down there was that
thing about Prince Philip being dead and
then there was the court that he said in
the late eighties rose like I want to
come back as a disease to bring down the
population really say that yeah I mean I
don't even know though you said that
it's just he's a sarcastic bastard
though isn't he what a vicious sense of
humor he's got it just so nice well the
Queen loves him she she loves her stiff
upper lip and a stiff upper [__] oh [__]
me you Cyrus the Queen said back off by
the way no Kovac there was a chat about
that book and being dead wasn't there
yeah that was being covered up I got
quite excited for a little while because
a royal death means days off I do think
that the only person in the world
potentially who was happy about this
right now
the Queen is Prince Andrew the Ives it
yes I thank god this all quite down for
this I can just get back to there the
little boys
yeah no genuinely like that's that he's
the only [__] out there who
taught me about this they took the heat
off him is when they say it really did
it really [__] did yeah you went we
can just get back to normal life and
everyone around him when we still heard
this year I just thought was interesting
some of the things that came out so
Pogba put a Twitter about Dudley Hamming
which I guess his heart was in the right
place but it was terrible what he's
basically saying is cover your mouth
smart yeah because the other day I was
walking down the street this guy in
front me to faint Willian dubbing isn't
really the technique we want to be no
you want to sneeze sort of so that is
good covering the whole face no but it
can we not just tell people the [__]
like you know it's almost Bettany's
there Dena you're saying your sink dad
and on their hero's tapping on the Rona
alright alright just bang you know then
you're out it's fine and you look cool
as well people in many ways you can
style it out people don't go step away
from him he's got a cough because they
just go he just must be dabbing yeah
yeah that's what he does yeah but but
isn't test scores yeah it's fine I think
a majority of the population so sooner
than you all right now I'm only gonna
put this out there and I think they
probably look about and go Paul Pogba
said it so I'm going to do you look at
that and go that's rodillas
other people and go well if Paul said it
must be truly all Paul and the Italians
were segments from the bulkan is now a
lot of people got taken for mugs with
pissed adored nor thought was true
though no there were Italians singing
from the balconies but if you listen to
the audio the ki one wasn't real I heard
many different versions of that same
clip for say we listen to the audio it's
clearly a concert yeah l'amour gue yeah
good ol care sighs look whose new stuff
it would raise my spirits in look that's
good yeah I don't like that I wanna get
my tail like that do you know what I do
like destined for greatness
Oh known for my lateness I got mine for
free ya know sometimes you know a funny
thing
we actually got free copies of FIFA ones
so we're sort of like - oh man you like
top of your money just like old and
white yeah but and if they take their
faces off but sometimes I this is the
thing right no offense of the lads but
destined for greatness is my guilty
pleasure like it's something that it my
age yeah with my experience in music I
shouldn't love by [__] NAB City right
and to a point where the lyrics are
about being better than other people
yeah right so when I'm on rocket Li you
relate I actually typed some of the
lyrics into the victims of my goals as
victims of my goals so what are you
saying I score victims of my goals I'll
just put a d4g and I'll just like let
them wonder like what does that mean
yeah and then a score gonna go
sure destined for greatness d4 gern and
then but then sometimes randomly I'll
just keep going and I've got known for
my lateness never like the fakeness like
confuse the good thing is if you score a
late goal go known for my lateness is in
my own company I'll just do things that
only I will enjoy we will enjoy and
that's fine to make you some
I also this will make you laugh I think
I said this on a show recently I've
taken up piano
Oh brah so I've got a piano at home
right do you know the first song I
learned to play on it was there so I
mean it should be but it wasn't it was
Robbie Williams she's the one oh great
song was her it's actually quite I'm not
saying Robbie's what's beautiful about
Robbie Williams songs they're brilliant
in their simplest nor if I heard do a
lockdown
yeah I'd like to do it with Robbie
Williams absoutely yeah although I get
the feeling that he will let us know
we're near his house right no absolutely
but luckily we know the address or yeah
and I'm good at kicking doors yeah
Robbie we know you're in there and that
shot all along yeah we could he could be
what McCauley where the City bandits
yeah which one of you you're definitely
the little one you're not annoying
you're yeah Danny you're Leto as long as
you have the iron to fall on your face
sure we had the girl who licked the
toilet seat did you see her I get the
thing that was pre pre this but she put
that out as like coronavirus test or
whatever yeah that's when I Salinger
sucked my cough what oh she the one she
took my offer but now you know what kind
of girl she oh my god she's into licking
toilets relieved my god what was worse
having my [__] in your mouth or licking
a toilet seat lowest on the clear seas
do like are you seen I just taught the
side note that Lord our roads is doing
serious views for those boys right no
like oh yeah of course really like gold
mined yeah well done of course well done
yes I'm sure the vlogs are very
compelling my god me I'm happier much
because there was a point where it felt
like it wouldn't come back I don't know
like when you hit it doesn't matter who
you are PewDiePie ksi Logan any of the
big careers they have their ups and
downs and then you but there's a point
where sometimes it can be a while since
you had a big video or a run and it's
good when they I think it's important
that these types stay where they are you
know what I mean we've seen our friends
going out a lot during this period more
runs right so coronavirus was announced
and right and is you know they packed it
on FIFA etcetra etcetra he comes out
he's in the kit yeah yeah I've got a
virus way I thought finally lockdown in
London we should all treat this very
seriously say Knight geo and Elliott to
the friends of ours from the show
there's been a pub launched near where
we live like this look onto the [__]
launch I message Brian ours that is
unbelievable these guys are morons like
what is wrong with you that you think
going to a pub is a good idea
on that launch le I'm necessarily it's
like what you're doing is like I'm just
in a pub I just couldn't believe it
yeah uh uh this is the thing I didn't I
wouldn't do that myself but I did go up
the gym oh you see this they say the gym
is bad for spread ya know this is in my
head I walked in the gym complete
wasteland tumbleweed MD yeah that's
disease all of them it died in my head
I'm like I'm a really taking any chances
here there's no one [__] here poor
from me know where you take I suppose if
you were coughing on things you were
giving other people that well I made
sure the coffin everything just side
confirmed it was all my German quality
my germs yeah yeah good Laden but yeah
when you saw someone else you tell me
the whole time you're in there there was
no one else there not one person so you
were in the gym alone is that gym that
closed I think it's still open by don't
expect will be open that much longer
a few people will be surprised that you
don't have a home gym do you know what I
mean yeah but I've got to get that like
I need to get like that frame of mind
almost going to a gym for me as a pro so
I have my music on yeah and it's like
badass music gets you in that for your
main and then when I step foot in it's a
different place yeah different me yeah I
guess with John then Lawrence yeah you
become least in a sense believe in Bruce
I've put a like I put some selfies out
on Instagram and stories of me
bench-pressing if you want to check that
out it's true Geordie official on
Instagram but believe iris sends me a
little message is going I like what
you're wearing for the gym a prison
stuff yeah it's not because Bruce is
like an old-school Geordie block so he's
like nah but the point is is he's used
to seeing all of these tight t-shirt gym
short type [__] and like nothing wrong
with Jim sure I but you know what I mean
yeah it's they make some great holes in
the gym rather than just getting in and
working and my attitude is I I'm here to
lift [__] yeah I'm not here to like you
know I'm not here to go recent I only
put stuff up because I'm aware that like
the only way I'm gonna get [__] brand
deals and this is cuz I'm always in the
gym I just don't talk about it a lot and
I realize to be honest I watched per
saying that I was like I just realized
if you shout about it people will give
you money now absolutely so yeah I'm
sure
yeah you know if anything no before then
you should be going to the gym
completely naked so your unbranded
people that's shown about it yes yeah
you should be going I am not wearing any
clothes there's no space every week yeah
I think you'll see that you can get
tattoos much more lift and pick away
yeah yeah logo tattooed around your
[__] for you if you don't already I
don't know I've never seen it so has
Trump Slater's tweet by the way after
this has just come out an hour ago it
says I always treated the Chinese virus
very seriously they call it the Chinese
voters yep this is actually today yet
the Chinese virus very seriously and
have done a very good job from the
beginning including my very early
decision to close the borders from China
against the wishes of almost all many
lives were saved the fate news narrative
is disgraceful and false there's a man
who's trying to convince himself of
something but this is a single it's like
you can you can make some right
decisions but also not do enough in
other areas sure but he he literally
just rewrites everything in order to
paid himself out to be
I think I'm a hero yeah he's the the sad
thing is is smart people can look at him
and go you [__] fool but it's a bit
like what you said earlier is you know
if my father says dub on them [__]
hater another yeah then you some people
got million and yeah yeah he's that guy
isn't here it's also amazing because I
imagine he leaves the toilet seat up at
home and Milania goes did you leave the
toilet seat up neros deliberately what
is amazing is that what was it a week
ago we were literally laughing at his
statement going they seemed gonna age
well never have we been proven so right
so fast he was everyone we've only got
15 people that's it
done lockdown went well sorted this is
it now one of them you know she could be
doing bad that's don't yeah she
definitely could have been doing better
when Tom Hanks
had it every I think that was going to
became real for a lot of people and his
wife second name is Wilson it was
laughing about it
that that was a bit of an annoying thing
for me because it was almost as if until
celebrities get it we didn't believe
that it was a real thing yeah that's sad
but true and and like when so when
footballer started getting it Arteta
lost the manager had it everyone said oh
my god I can't what is this and yeah but
I was sitting there obviously knowing
I'd already had it and I was like all
right you know he's I didn't tweet about
it yeah but nobody liked the reaction
like we've got stop football I stopped
it I'm don't Mira I'm not saying we
should have continued the football but
just I think people idolize these
celebrities and stars so much that it's
like not my football manager yeah no way
could our tester have gotten it yeah and
it says do you wonder how these guys get
it that people are humans where was he
that he would have got it well this is
where all this is the thing when you
hear how far and wide it's gone now
idris elba the fella who was with Drake
the other day when Drake was trending
just because he was with some more all
right and other people who party of [__]
Boris Johnson's huh like locked up
you're vulnerable
keep them safe because this [__] is
going to be everywhere and if you're not
if you're not no but I don't want to
scare monger but it's just the time to
stop it's been and gone we've missed it
missed up yeah you know correct so the
trains gone accept it and just
understand yeah this is yeah no I and
it's here for this is the weird thing
this is the really weird thing is how
people think it's gonna be I think it
was on the Rogan podcast that they might
have described it really well yeah it
was like people think this is gonna be
like a bit of bad weather and it will
clear up in the summer no like it you're
gonna have this is going to be talked
about for quite a few years now yeah
it's not gonna be away for a minute yeah
and there's chance you could come back
there's a chance it could be manifesting
somewhere else there is also a chance I
mean if you believe the the conspiracy
theories that this is like a soft launch
for something much worse wow that's
scary yeah I think what we are seeing is
this is PlayStation 1 yeah
this is PlayStation 1 and PlayStation 2
is so much better
like do you know me position five been
announced oh yeah can we just focus on
the positive Lauren's yeah not the
positive tests I think that is the
worrying thing no so I I wanted to play
a little game with you of what do you
think these people think for instance
you know we've had David Icke on the
podcast and he has said a few cuckoo
things but he has also said that there
is this virus that could control the
population in some way oh you said the
house in framing in it have you seen any
David Icke stuff recently some crates I
know I listen to a little bit of
something the other day right like I
said I get to a point where I switch off
of things
only because I get just all right that's
enough you know you especially with
conspiracy level stuff but to be fair I
think I was framing it in a way of this
is how they'll use this to accomplish
what they right now so rather than I
didn't hear him specifically talk about
they did this they made this that hours
that be he just was like they'll use
this likely to use anything for their
own advantage is someone said why would
they want people and I know we're going
down conspiracy theories little bit of
fun someone said we've gotta make them
more so that's why would they want so
many people indoors what are they doing
outside I was like that's smart are they
testing bombs are they you know are they
working out how to control the
population it's not the virus you want
to be scared of it's the people who tell
you about the virus cuz who in this room
has met someone who's had the virus part
from you obviously and we that's not
even a confirmed case yeah I know but
like yeah it could have just been a
really bad it was I got a bit triggered
clients by people saying everyone
tweeting out but like being genuinely
like yeah I'm self isolating them right
and uh and all I'm doing social
distancing I'm like well you're sitting
in the house watching Netflix like yeah
no but why not just say I'm just staying
in like how many not just because you
have to yeah but you have to show that
you're doing the right thing these
people are trying to be leaders Brian
and you're making
one of them you know I took I've been
doing the [__] since like I was fought
in MIT when I had grand theft auto very
first time I was doing
you just didn't know what I was self
isolate yeah for many years I'll go away
mom I'm self isolated Ising I'm doing
born for this [__] do you think that I
mean in nine months from now there is a
possibility there will be a lot more
kids being born I bet you I think
there'll also be a lot more divorces I
mean yeah yeah it'll joke both ways III
bet there's a lot of people who realize
because there's a lot of people who if
if we had to do a sustained period of
time indoors there he has sat the sad
truth about so many relationships rely
on like yes having a break from one
another and I think that's very healthy
but the test of a relationship or test
of people in general whether it be
boyfriend-girlfriend
or whether you're with family members
however when you can't escape each other
[__] mate it doesn't matter who you are
you ground each other states right so
goddamn I wouldn't surprise me if people
end up not being able whether it's
people moving out from their parents
people separating a lot of people if
they had to do this for a long time and
hopefully they don't it will be like
[__] a lot always I think if you are
living with your parents or something
right now that must be frustrating
because you're not the one who's in
control of your own home yeah I'm quite
happy and obviously you're quite happy
you've got control of your own flat you
can do what you want in it if you want
you can play playstation or hours if you
want you can order food or do this or do
that
someone who's got someone who they feel
have power over them that might be a
really not nice feeling and you might
feel quite isolated at latter point ask
me for a photograph the other day and
they came like right close to me yeah
for the photo and I was like in my head
I was like yeah I probably shouldn't be
doing this but I don't want to be that
guy so why not why don't you sort of go
hey can we just you know I don't know
I'm also I'm just so accepting of like
I'm [__] like a I've already had it in
my head right me I just do too many
things that involve being around people
- don't get me wrong I'll do my bit when
I came away from
people around me and all that and like
we'll keep our distance or that's why
the table was made so big but yeah we've
had it in mind but I'm just the type of
guy who'd probably end up with a sore
foot bit the other side is I think a lot
of people are worrying they can't get
what they want from the supermarket
right here's my tip be more creative
when you're walking around if you see
something on a shelf you like I've never
used noodles before sure I'll have a go
with the noodles or if the shelves are
cleared in one aisle go on to the X see
what you can cook with in there there's
a world food aisle that I've never been
down in Sainsbury's Wow pee milk is
something I've discovered so P milk who
even knew what the [__] p mo was it's
amazing in a smoothie all right I've
made this smoothie as I've crammed as
much spinach as I can into a nutribullet
really I then poured pea milk in I've
got some maple syrup there's a little
raspberry and natural this is nice no no
seriously it's amazing right if you've
got a new trouble at home try this a
whole pack of spinach so we're talking
like a big bag a bullet a nutribullet
you know what most things you know what
women put on their cliffs I understand
what you're saying here but that's your
framing of the world I hope I know
you're honorable so it's a like a
blender all right but it's nicer thought
then right but the brand is nutribullet
well use a spade no
but it's a great brand elendor yeah now
I got one of these when remember
Boltwood the guy who produced for us to
work with us yeah check somebody else
confused ok so he went to Thailand for
the trip of a lifetime
that was him on his honeymoon yeah he's
come home oh [__] he probably thought
yeah come on I may have to you know
change where work and stuff like that
and my life savings it yeah he's
probably spend quite a bit money other I
mean but was a sensible guy we know he
would have not made a mistake like what
I would we're living on a pound a herb
but you know coming home that this [__]
must have been like what the now a
couple of months ago Boltwood night he's
very sensible guy but we went for a
drink after a show right and it's just
him and I and Rovin we don't Rove him
the camera guy and just sitting there
and Boltwood had this had like a flask
right about this big full of something
he called fuel now is I was quite
curious about fuel I was like hmm this
is what is that he was like it's like a
powder it's got everything you need in
it
a day of nutrition and he was I and if I
give you my code then I get some free
stuff you get some free stuff I was like
cool I'll sign up we're boiling out at
this point the deals are all signed
everything is good with stupid Tuoba I'm
around about 40 pounds later I bought
two months supply of fuel now Huell I've
actually never tried it I think I tried
like one bit and I was like not for me
but I bought two months of it so I just
sort of popped it on top of the
cupboards five minutes gonna come in
handy
my my my girlfriend threw it away I was
telling Baldwin this is [__] you do
really yeah he was like it's meal
replacement yeah but then he was
starving later on the day was i I'm
really hungry I'm like buy a
cheeseburger bro but you went too far
the other way you could you just bought
a spinach salad or a nutribullet two of
to blend stuff up though now I've just
gotten really creative with the stuff
that I found in the aisles so I've been
like mmm no raspberries today letting
create rice and blackberry is that just
throwing stuff in the blender now Bryan
but when you think of it you go hmmm
spinach but pea milk now I'll tell you
this cow milk no way pea milk everywhere
mainly because people are looking on the
shelves again what the [__] is P milk
why would I want that it tastes as good
as cow milk it tastes it's almost the
consistency of single cream it is really
good in a blender and it contains so
much cows as a problem we've got rock
and protein is we're getting encourage
to do social distancing all this
[__] and stay inside
now milk the problem is people ain't got
the [__] money to do that forever
and while Piers Morgan and many of us
can sit there and stay in for six months
order and [__] deliver room and be
fine most of us have got to get out
there and earn a crust right and he
liked this so this can only go on so
long and like back in the day when coal
miners just had to accept [__] I'm
putting my life on the line
I need [__] money many people are
gonna have to kind of come to that
conclusion and have no choice in the
matter unless we are talking about
currently freezing mortgages and
freezing rent there's still not enough
people have to live on food
like most people I know live week the
week like in my whole in my whole circle
it's not a good way of living yeah it's
it's it's it's the only way of living
for many people yes it there's not a
choice in the matter
living paycheck-to-paycheck sadly and
there it's very normal
yeah it's in 2020 while we can advise
this that and the other you you know the
lack of money is going to bring people
out of their homes sooner I [__]
layer and I tell you another thing you
know for me sitting there when I hope
the football comes back soon because I
need [__] I need to make some money
and then make football shows and all
that
there's many powerful rich old white
dudes out there who are going to make
sure the [__] football comes back
soon because it's the aerialist yeah
they've got hundreds of millions on this
[__] we're broadcasting rights and
thought all this [__] is on the line so
you better believe well we're all what
I'm trying to say is we're all doing the
right thing now yeah but only for so
long big girls change after that welcome
situation money changes morals short
that on a t-shirt [__] there's actually
great genuine money changes made in a
post-apocalyptic society where the TJ
merch yeah MCM get that we're bringing
out towards the end of the month
check check socials I'll be posting one
that's live I'm also gonna make a
t-shirt which can we can we get every
what about your mixing messages now
Lawrence oh okay my t-shirt our
collaborative I'm not getting in there I
will do that when Shirley's talk weird
are you know - yeah yeah no one is dying
here but you are clearly not dying
look at you oh he's the funny thing
right I went out for a walk in the park
the other day right maybe you some
people say that's a cool thing to do
there was an empty basket ball court
fantastic I'm gonna head back down there
tomorrow join me but there are plenty
people running I think we're gonna see
and a population who are not only
incredibly fit there will be also
population you put on weight so you're
eating it'll be the the stealing TVs and
running from houses with a TV on I do
worry
right but honestly I've gotten so good
at Rockley because of all this [__]
I've just stayed in and played rocket
League and obviously message to losers
destined for greatness lyrics there are
a few so while there are a few
industries that are struggling and while
Donald Trump said it sure we love the
cruise industry
all right let's great in the street big
industry only fans can only be getting
stronger right now only funds and gaming
and gaming recession-proof people want
to play games and look at tits yeah and
included not necessarily in that order
although bosses yeah GTA nailed it
you know because I paired this trailer
hubs all stuff like that I'm also come
at spin you know what it is Rockstar all
right I'm calling me rock rock star
sorry I thought you're talking to me now
I like this nickname how the [__] has it
been seven years since we had a grand
theft auto made and I know we've had Red
Dead Redemption or whatever seven years
I've been waiting on a new Grand Theft
Auto I start red can you believe that
how the [__] are you gonna wait seven
years in between iterations of it has to
be it has to be at a point where it's so
good now I think people expect their
launch history soon they did last time
and release it for two consoles you know
you're gonna get us on the pace interval
and the fibers like you're gonna double
up again are you maybe yes [__] a
noise one I wrote I wrote some notes of
stuff that I've just been feeling down I
just thinking if you're a believer in
God what must you make of all this thing
what do you think God would make have we
annoyed him or is this the devil's
action or did God so ago we did schedule
this or why do they blame and the devil
for this what do you I like to believe
there's a god really why I don't know I
just have a feeling in my in my
self-consciousness I feel like there's
something out there you know what I mean
like a higher power I don't know I just
think it's pretty [__] amazing that
we're all here and I've you know you
have all these feelings and you eat I
guess you like to believe that there's
more to it than what there probably is
why would that make it any more profound
well it would it would make it more
profound if it we were created by
something out there and it wasn't just
an accident that happened I think it
would be a deep it would be deeper but
once you find out that God exists right
what created God what goes beyond that
there's there's never you're never gonna
use absolute alright
understand yeah I think you're never
gonna get the answer that you want and
it's always when you get to it's a bit
I'll going for an answer
it's it's it I'm quite happy with the
ending of the movie being the black
screen or the credits rolling them I
find out more about it but I believe
that there's a God by Dawn I don't
necessarily need that to be that you
don't think it's one of the traditional
gods though you think I think it's more
of an energy thing going on yeah there's
a creator of the universe that is beyond
why my little brain can conceive can I
give you a scenario that I saw the other
day that actually made me quite angry
because I went through this as a kid
right I grew up in a a I was raised but
not raised in a Catholic household
what was your your local pastor called
or flatly no actually what it wasn't
definitely I mean if I was you know you
know when you look at Harvey Weinstein
and you go rape this mmm - look at this
priest you go steer without molester
really yeah
that's odd isn't it I think it's more
the uniform he wore that it made me come
over here to file anyway um I cried as a
kid because my mum told me I don't
believe in God and obviously I went to
school and the teacher told me at school
if you don't believe in God you're not
going to heaven I was devastated I was
hired I was like oh my god so my mom's
not gonna go to heaven mom had a good
answer which was like I'm a still a good
person God will know that blah blah blah
I watched a video that was tweeted by
the church the other day and it was like
her little public gathering we have on
Twitter although I think they are I
don't know I mean the Vatican so the
Pope or the Pope is sitting there if
he's not already got that ballin on my
gold throne right now we're all worried
about this virus yeah exactly
he's doing that he's trying to just pop
there he's so dubbing on them that yeah
imagine if the Pope had tweeted that
yeah the Pope says dab
he's sitting there on his throne or
whether it's just a little chair now cuz
I think he's downgraded it a little bit
you know not good for the image a little
bit of your slow Bishop one side bishop
the other there's a little kid with a
microphone in front this genuinely made
me sob I watched I was really upset this
kid walks up to Mike
phone and a little Italian kid so he's
got these big Italian eyes and really
sweet swept to the side hair really
sweet little face or Don Corleone ooh
bene he just breaks down he can't cry
can't even ask his question and it was
that he lost his dad not long before
that mm-hmm but his dad had told him
that he didn't believe in God
mm-hmm and he was worried that dad
wouldn't go to heaven and I thought how
[__] mean do you have to be to a kid
to make them even question the fact that
their dad wouldn't go to heaven and then
to take that video exploit it and tweet
it and pretend as if as if it's all
right the Pope doesn't really give a
committed answer so whether his dad's
gone to heaven he sort of gone but if
your dad was a good man and I wonder if
that's maybe why the kids crying let's
put a word in for him with a big guy
yeah but I'm like no the kid was on
Santa's good list it's so mean to make a
child even think that in the first place
they've done worse though wasn't there
yes that means that he can wheels was
his also land tuck when he left them cuz
I think he's done all right was it there
was a point where the Pope put his hand
on the side of the kid's head almost
like if I was the Pope a pride I was a
little bit like I get that he's loving
in effect what else I like it when they
cry sad no I can totally empathize why
that would get you and in watching a
little kid cries always [__] doesn't
matter what mood you're in
yeah I mean apart from obviously when
you like it would make rise well that
wasn't me that was me the Pope yeah yeah
that's not offensive at all yeah all the
warm women cry it's still [__] I mean I
suppose if she's got tears rolling down
her face she's not necessarily crying
yeah although sometimes it's just gag
reflex of it right Oh people need this
entertainment this could have been
released after the lockdown as they say
I think it will probably be really
hoping for that are we having from
what's a lockdown
if we're ready a lot more like got the
whiskey are you drinking a lot you know
she looked quite healthy at the moment
look like you've shed a few pounds or I
think I haven't been drinking more
I'm just mean just the same but I've
been training harder yeah I've got a lot
of anger in the gym lately I also had a
thought the other day one probably don't
have I Britian by the way paracetamol
not ibuprofen yeah okay good advice
although I feel like it for two hours in
these people is probably already they've
probably given up on it's because of the
blood pressure thing or whatever there
enjoy the temperature
I don't take ibuprofen to take your
temperature down but it actually affects
your immune system I see whereas
paracetamol doesn't so go with
paracetamol what if you're allergic to
be honest I think a lot of people knew
that because when I've been into Boots
recently they're all sold out so yeah
the likelihood is my words mean nothing
everyone's bought the paracetamol
already so [__] it you can't get
paracetamol anywhere there is there's
nowhere to get it now because again
people panic buying yeah it also comes
down to I thought what happened before
they perforated toilet paper yeah the
people just rip it before I guess or
I've never lived in a time where that
wasn't the case yeah like toilet paper
to me is just always existed do you not
I mean yeah there will have been a time
in the world where people will have
ripped their own toilet paper
that's so weird Martin oh yeah that's
genuinely like crazy to me that it
wouldn't come perforate it will so like
modern-day [__] on you like we all are
though bime to sin yeah we heard what
you're saying it's mental this isn't it
I mean it's crazy to think that at one
time we didn't perforate a toilet paper
you know what you were saying about how
with the Nigerians were like welcome to
my world sort of they're good like that
I wonder if people who naturally suffer
from anxiety and people who naturally
have this impending doom fear of death
depression I wonder if they're feeling a
little bit like that it's one like like
a lot of people have all of a sudden
joined the power pub yeah where it's
like because I've I've had a you know
I've admitted mentally I haven't been as
good as I have been I felt there's been
a lot of laws in the last year for me
and seeing everyone all of a sudden a
little bit afraid a little bit worried
and yet when we watch these
movies which are like about the end of
the world
or panic movies like 28 days later and
[__] like that it's all true really it
we would all just collapse in on
ourselves because our lack of being like
you know and in some movies how they all
band together at the end in you know the
matrix for example lego movie without
spoiling you know the whole point is
that the human race get together and
they bard together and they fight the
machines that wouldn't happen we'd all
we'd all break down we'd all
disintegrate we'd all go off in our own
little holes and eventually the machines
would sniff us out and they're
exterminate us right at the end you know
we wouldn't burn together we wouldn't do
that but that is after a long time so in
the matrix yes it took a long time for
us to get up I just wish aliy I think
you're right people's reaction would be
[__] I need to and I I do often will not
make it at that point that's what I'm
saying
all right I'd be sniffed out initially
because we're means well we but the
selfishness and in this the
self-preservation thing would would make
us not stick together and it was just
all brief don't I see that do you know
there are certain people who also
believe that this they almost want this
to happen so for instance there are some
evangelicals who believe that this is
part the end of the world they're
waiting for Jesus who or whoever to come
back and they think this is actually a
good thing
what I've met yeah I've I've met a
Jehovah's Witness before who said what
did they Swit nist she was she'd
witnessed the truth apparently right
they call it the truth you must tell me
about this I've never I've never heard
this before
I've definitely mentioned this
performance but the point is is they
believe Armageddon's coming yeah and the
film was released about 20 years ago no
great film now Armageddon is the end of
the world where basically from what I
understand
Java's Witnesses believe that the devil
has been cast down from heaven for an
angel in a way and he has basically been
given the teachers mark Perriman are you
do it better than if
you're gonna criticize me and this is
his attempt his own world and avenge our
way of seeing things eventually when
basically God stands back and lets him
make a complete tits of himself yeah
because God also can see the past the
present in the future he's going I know
where this one's going well
you idiots yeah so basically he's making
a prick out of himself by the way he's
ruling the world right and then
eventually Armageddon comes in which
that all ends right the dead or
resurrect that I think it is and then so
maybe this virus won't be all that bad
I'm basically like anyway if you live
through Armageddon you will you'll just
stay alive basically the whole time
right and I think there's some people
who won't get back but anyway the point
is that's horrible doesn't it this how
nice it's not a fairy tale but the but
the good thing is afterwards you live
off the land like Adam and Eve oh I
don't if the Leafs are included in that
do you remember all the people who died
in Armageddon oh we have to I can't calm
and carry on that kind of feel like if
you're not on the so what I can remember
is if you're not on the right side like
if you're you get judged if you're pure
of heart sighing we'll be fine and
there's a judgement call made on you
then oh okay so you're judged I mean
everyone goes that's I guess that's what
Judgment Day is isn't it that's all
point of what they're saying mmm so
anyway maybe that there a lot of them
will be a big thing and all this is it
then oh my god this is the beginning at
the end yeah and a lot of people are
thinking this this way when maybe few
weeks goes by him I like so I've got a
gun back to work now so I gotta risk it
so I think that's called presumptive
bias where basically what you do I don't
know if that's the right term but
basically when you're looking for
something to happen anyway when
something happens then you'll go see
yeah
so you're connecting dots not really odd
though aren't there because you're
ultimately a [__] and you know waste a
lot of your Sundays so that's part of
the problem is these people going ah
look it's happening and you're like or a
few people are ill and actually you're
you're stuck your fairy tales your
stories which aren't real yeah
actually unhealthy for the population
because you're trying to reinforce a
negative story so maybe maybe you should
grow up you know and stop reinforcing
what is ultimately bollocks you know and
so on you know if some people said so
some people tweeted me after I said I
don't believe in God recently and they
said that's offensive to me and I said
was offensive to me that you think that
I have to believe in God because you
believe in God and people who are on the
side of God or believe in a God don't
necessarily understand what it's like
and no one can understand what it's like
to be in another person's shoes
the virus is currently making us all
think about other people's shoes and
going [__] well what position are they
in what position are they not the shoes
themselves but the position of those
people are in yes brilliant they're
making us think about the positions
everyone else is in and there's
something quite nice about that because
and I'm not saying it's the silver
lining of the cloud but it is making us
wonder about other people when before we
were a bit more like or I just need to
think about my own world am i right am I
wrong all those kind of things isn't
it's forcing people to open up a little
bit I think in London more so because
it's such a disconnected city and it's
an amalgamation of so many different
basic AZ and backgrounds yeah so I
wonder after this sort of calm zone and
I believe it will calm we'll go back
normal
let me finish I wonder if if at least
initially people will be a little bit
more kind at the one another yeah and
there might be an appreciation for the
fact that yeah we kept the core to work
the day you know like it's actually
right a bit more appreciation for
getting the to just regular [__] so
there's that come the Overton Window you
know do you know as where someone takes
up such an extreme position that
normality changes towards the extreme
position so with the corona with with so
with the virus because it's so extreme
it means that our normality is taken
further towards a virus so we start to
appreciate the weird things a bit more I
don't know if I explained that very well
but basically because the things are so
bad under the virus
we get back to the normal [__] which is
already [__] in other ways the
populations mentality will be at least
things are back to normal and they'll
accept more of the [__] that goes on
rather than railing against it yeah I
can tell you now I definitely do that
yeah I just would yeah cuz I this [__]
is so stressful I just want it to be
normal again
you know I mean I just want to watch
some football do you miss football yeah
but also I like like I just I like I
like doing the shows as well I really
enjoyed the kick off what's tough is
watching an old game in the same room
you know what I mean Lord you know like
just all of this like what's kind of
with you have seen Tony Ferguson versus
khabib nurmagomedov it's a fight that's
already been made four times from what I
recommend there from what I remember
like one thing they're allowed to do
they are allowed to make a fight and
just have that fight behind closed door
behind we can actually it's different
because the numbers that you're allowed
by regulations of government is like 50
yeah you could just put that one fight
on and the world would watch it still
and they'd still pay a fortune to watch
it yeah now one thing I would love no
comment 8us no audience core cultures
maybe you can just hear but I don't want
to hear anything I just want to I just
want to hear them the flat packing yeah
I want to hear that I want I want to
hear their breathing I want to hear what
they're saying to each other just for
one fight and I think it would be iconic
it would be so different because a crowd
is great but this would feel so Bruce
Lee it would feel so to the death like
not not actual death because we want
them this but it would feel like almost
the when he gets the kill oh really like
in terms of like true martial arts like
this in for like all of the people in
the attendance they like sadly I've been
a lot of fights in the UK like it's it's
coked-up not right is it they were
wanting a [__] you know they watch
the USA and then you go out looking for
some victim to beat the hell out
you also look like someone who could be
a big target it's like if I can take
that one out I can take anyone luckily
for me they don't target me it's it's
it's the little guys in the pub I feel
sorry for afterwards when they come out
with it you know but anyway the point of
into the fights with Jo but I think
they'll be so sick if they made that I
just put this on as an event for my
talking to me yeah like to hear the food
of the cracker as the leg hits the
[__] flesh inside Fight Club but live
I just didn't do it
day not why make this happen like me
just give us something to watch because
it's [__] boring right it's almost
like play so many games are up believe
it so many Lord in it you can you can
message them are you bored in it no but
like you know I'm bored generally now
like it's this is [__] I think we're all
bored people are tweeting Netflix
directly go and may release something
people are saying bring the PlayStation
5 release forward like do give the
points is a lot of people I'm a guy
who's used to like we're going for
meetings we're trying to get this rice
bran to work with us we're we're having
a lot of things we're try to book guests
and all of that one's meeting anyone no
I'm I've literally had some guests in
the pipeline and they're like bro go
away want me no it's like [__]
everything's on hold the whole world's
on hold and I I'm a personally just
likes to call about and that's part of
it is everyone's being like yeah you
shouldn't leave the house you selfish
[__] and and it is yeah but also
Mendeley I'm the type of person like for
example if I don't go out at the gym or
at least once in a week I just feel like
[__] ok can you do anything types and
fury talks like that yeah like I'm not
quite that level obviously he's funny in
a heavyweight champion of the world but
what I mean is mentally I feel the same
like if I'm not active physically I just
feel like you started a cage a caged
animal like you know that moment when
I'm bench pressing like or doing their
heavy squat or something it's like I'm
going to a point where you know when
people piss you off throughout a week
and
like an element where you want to hit
someone or whatever now I don't have
this along I don't have this a lot but
if often if I've had a really stressful
phone call hmm or some company hasn't
paid us yet
just flipping out a random example this
doesn't happen often there's no
correlation between what's happening in
real life there I show you but let's say
there is let's say there when I hold on
to that bar it's just like mm-hmm
I just let it all go you know what I
mean and if I don't have that release
it's like there's a build up there of
like pissed off energy there you know
what I mean it's not good for me do you
think you need to approach that at the
source rather than going to the gym to
kill no but there's there's just
multiple things you can do and and I'm
not saying it's always down to build up
anger but I'm just in sometimes
generally I've just got it's it's like
we're made to get out there and do stuff
where we're as animals we are actually
supposed to be active like a hell of a
lot more active than I am even yeah so
when I don't do that there's just like
the endorphins aren't there filled [__]
I feel like with like RJ fat lump of
[__] you know what I mean I mean yeah do
stuff but do you think if you if you
change your lifestyle now this is a good
almost reset where you can go maybe I'll
try meditating this week or maybe I'll
try I was thinking about doing squat on
the house and [__] we really I'm dead I
see there's home workouts you can do on
YouTube that are pretty good so if it
comes to that I'll just be like press
ups and all that [__] yeah you'll
come back looking great no but like
that's cool but like I don't know this
it's just we all need to just find
little things to keep ourselves occupied
yeah no not piano why not
what's wrong with piano it's just weird
why I'm happy for you but also like it's
20 minutes yeah go for it go for it it's
20 minutes yeah we could do it you we
can collapse and lame to be honest I was
just happy I could play Robbie Williams
song but if yeah if you got a lock down
how would you think you'll find it I was
saying this I'm an only child I've spent
so much time on my own as a kid I play
on my own for hours while those people
saying to me how it makes me feel really
uncomfortable
I'm really not enjoying this I was like
funny I feel like I was I had like an
almost like a childhood like feeling
where I was like I'm on my own I can do
this it was quite obvious had spent a
lot of time on the phone to my parents
because of the situation there but apart
from that when I was on my own I was
actually like oh this is this has just
reminded me of what it's like to be on
my own as an only child I'm absolutely
fine and actually I enjoy my own company
like you do yeah I think I've certainly
record like I've actually unplugged my
PlayStation and my xbox and all those
things to stop myself from going over
and doing those things so force me to do
other more efficient stuff rather than
the light piano or like just sort
including so I've sorted out like two
whole bags of charity clothes that when
the charity shop will reopen I'm just
going to take the clothes down go go
I've sorting through photographs at the
moment so there's loads of photos of you
that are just sitting there ready to go
yeah so there's loads of stuff where I'm
like oh like this has made me more
efficient and actually maybe it's time
in my life you need that rather than
being like [__] I've got to find
something to do it's also great because
I'm also discovering other things like
that
there's loads of sports Russia is still
weirdly having loads of sports yeah
doesn't seem to be affecting your pocket
there for hopefully well we'll be back
soon hopefully this lockdown [__]
doesn't happen but if it does then it
does and the good thing if you do go
into lockdown just remember there's over
120 episodes of the true jody podcast
need watch and they've got multiple
adverts on them if they haven't been to
monetize it is actually pretty amazing
how much content we've made over these
last few years I was gonna tweet that
yeah there's a whole playlist of stuff
we've done list of like the football
holiday I've got a vlog playlist a
podcast playlist and a true news
playlist we love you guys we'll see you
soon hopefully sound like a goodbye
message stop Nichols what is a football
comes back and we can make a living
again and hopefully everyone survives
and the grandparents lives stop making
this sound like a good bye bye Oh bye
guys
bye hopefully we live he's at that point
where he's really hungry and he can't
keep podcasting until there's food
so yes